[Music]
what's up Wolfgang I hope the majority
of you have seen Avengers infinity war
by now and if you haven't I hope you go
see it this weekend in this video we are
still talking about Avengers infinity
war so as always there will be some
spoilers in this video
Granta days aren't as big as the others
are but if you haven't seen the movie
it's still a spoiler so here we go in
today's video we will be talking about
why Thanos new Iron Man but before we
get started be sure to enter our
giveaway for your chance to win a full
speaker system all you have to do is
subscribe to my channel subscribe to the
stupendous wave leave a like and drop a
comment below with your favorite
superhero so we found out an Avengers
infinity war on Titan that Thanos know
Stark after a pretty epic scene of
tano's fighting some of the Avengers and
parts of the guardians of the galaxy
Tony Stark or Iron Man jumps in front of
Thanos and says you throw another moon
at me and I'm gonna lose it and then
Thanos replies by saying Stark Tony then
ask you know me aunt Anna says I do
you're not the only one cursed with
knowledge so this led to so many
questions
and obviously the main question being
how does Stannis know Tony Stark many of
you have been asking me which is why I
made this video and I have two theories
on how Thanos could know start you know
the question I get asked most often is
Tony how do you go to the bathroom soon
just like that my first theory which I
actually think is the less likely of the
theories to be true is that Thanos knows
Tony Stark from the soulstone when Tony
asks Thanos you know me and Thanos
replies I do you're not the only one
cursed with knowledge I think he's
implying something here when Thanos went
to retrieve the soul stone and he ran
into Red Skull Red Skull said it is my
curse to know all who journey here so
anyone who may have traveled there to
retrieve the soul stone Red Skull knows
but they clearly did not obtain the soul
stone because it is still there but
maybe a curse comes with actually
obtaining the soul stone between Thanos
sacrificing Gamora and him
getting the soul stone in his hand he
enters a sort of dream state
it looks like he's sort of floating in
clouds and then eventually he ends up in
water with the soul stone in his hand he
could have possibly been in Soul world
during that time and what if when he was
in Soul world since he's getting the
soul stone he actually found out
everything about who has had the soul
stone before and it also showed him who
will eventually get the soul stone this
would have given Thanos an idea of who
Tony Stark is and he could have possibly
heard his voice and seen him because
keep in mind that Thanos didn't
recognize him at first just based on his
Iron Man armor so my next theory which
isn't really much of a theory it's more
of common sense is that Diana snows Tony
Stark because he's the one that sent a
giant nuke into his army in space if I
had an army and I was attacking Earth
and that army was in space and you would
come tell me that some dude from Earth
threw a huge nuclear bomb at my army
into space blowing it up I don't want to
know who that guy was cuz let's not
forget that just like Tony Stark
Thanos himself is a genius and Fanus has
conquered many worlds in an attempt to
save them and you don't come across with
out a little intel on them and let's not
forget the post-credits scene of the
first Avengers movie where the other is
talking to Thanos and he says humans
they are not the cowering wretches we
were promised and then he says they are
not to be underestimated
knowing this I'm sure that US did his
fair share of research especially
knowing that there are Infinity stones
on earth in doing so I'm sure that he
came to respect Tony Stark for
everything that he's done and I'm sure
he respects and admires Tony for trying
to save his planet after all that's how
Dana's got his start trying to save his
own planet Titan we know that Tony Stark
has the respect of Thanos he says it in
the movie he says you have my respect
Stark and he even says I hope they
remember you to me this is the most
likely theory to be true there are other
theories out there like maybe Thanos is
having dreams about Tony just like Tony
had dreams of Thanos and maybe Loki told
Thanos about
Tony Stark but I think this is the most
likely one to be true so those are my
two theories on how Thanos knows who
Tony Stark is what do you guys think of
these theories and have you heard any
different ones that are kind of crazy
and out there let me know in the
comments below I'd love to hear them
if you enjoy my videos please subscribe
to my channel to join the wolf gang
and again another reminder about our
speaker giveaway all you have to do to
enter is subscribe to my channel
subscribe to the stupendous wave leave a
like and drop a comment below with your
favorite superhero thank you so much for
watching woof woof
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]